again though you get to sit next to the
quarterback rights and Arnold and now
Tony Romo yes sorry that's just what
happens this quarterback thing man
you stay over there host yeah but Sam
Dawg we spend time with them I said one
only coming out in the draft one of the
pro player comparisons I kind of
compared it to use your style of play I
said Tony Romo the way he manipulates
the pocket and can move around and
subtly move and make throws so we're
interested in just your thought on him
yes pacifically and then of course some
of the other rookie cubies that have
jumped out to you without making any
glaring statements yeah but I'm about to
yes I actually think Sam Darnell is got
a chance to end up at some point right
to be the best quarterback in the
National Football League okay and the
whole league and the whole league I
actually think he's the best quarterback
to come out in a while period kind of
glaring yeah they've heard this some
people just have this rare ability for
nuance that I say our feel you know we
talk about you feel the tackles creeping
up in you and you're getting ready to
throw you just move and you don't even
know why you don't even know why you
moved it's just an innate feeling it's
just a subtle gift that I feel like it
for spatial awareness in your ability
just a sense and you're just you
shuffled two steps and didn't even know
you did it
until you rewatch the deal and when I
see that it doesn't come along that
often when you find it now it's like
okay when you have that the ceiling is
very high yeah you had that dude yeah
and that's why there's a similarities
further along than I am in the sense
that it took me years to get the base to
be strong and set where he's coming in
like that which is more Peyton Manning
ish that then I've seen of anybody
coming out and you know I know it's a
pretty bold statement stuff but I'm
willing based on what I've seen yeah I
feel very confident like I don't know if
he's gonna have a good year this year
but I guarantee within the next three
years yeah Sam Donald is for real
that's awesome what was your rookie
experience like do you remember that
looking back jeez yeah yeah it's a
little different probably than what you
guys are doing oh man myself
Jerry learned my name in year four three
now I think Parcells is my coach yes and
you were told to be quiet get in a room
listen to what I say and shut up one day
who was rookie ER and I was like I
wanted to impress coach hey and I was
he's like we're doing the wet ball drill
today and he's like we're gonna dump the
ball in here and I want you guys all
wearing gloves there's me Quincy Carter
Chad Hutchinson oh my gosh and he's like
we're you're all gonna wear gloves and
you're gonna get there and you're gonna
we're gonna practice that and so I'm
like not plating you know I'm from
Wisconsin
okay and the snow we play in the rain
playing like I'm gonna show him that I'm
good and you're trying to always impress
your coaches rookie it's some like coach
we're walking off the price was I just
wanted to tell you he's like what what
spit it out
I'm like I just I don't need to wear the
gloves I throw away you know yeah you're
good he's just like oh [ __ ] Romo you
don't know it effing thing put the glove
on don't talk to me I love it and I was
like okay I'm about this guy I mean I
knew about him but Gruden I was the guy
2005 you became the starter was it six
it was six so it was preseason of six
and we're sitting in a meeting and
training camp and True Blood says the
starter yeah that's cowboy starter I
mean Tony Romo okay yeah yeah journeyman
from Eastern you know and yeah and
Gruden comes in one day and on the
clicker he goes let me just show you
guys something I'm gonna show you the
new starting quarterback for the Dallas
Cowboys nothing what is he talking about
he goes this Tony Romo guy I mean watch
we're gonna watch some drives at Tony
Romo and I was like damn this guy is
kind of good it was my first real
knowledge of Tony the player to really
watch on a film and go I learn I learned
from an Atlantic City garbage man slash
bartender he was a Cowboys fan he goes
we got our new guides Tony Romo and I
was like this guy doesn't know and you
haunted my Eagles for like a decade
which was fantastic they wanted me a few
times yeah
the love affair stronger owner
quarterback Jerry for you or Kraft for
Tom ooh-ooh because Jerry loves oh my
gosh loves a battle that is a battle I
know how much it's like a dad thing is
it a grandfather thing like what's that
relationship like oh it'd be like a dad
dad yeah yeah I mean they're just I mean
even when I wasn't playing and I think
it was about 16 right and dad was
playing and her team was playing great
yes I swear Jerry was still slightly
uncomfortable that the team was winning
oukitel yeah and to me and he he was so
ecstatic he loved it right but whenever
he saw me his heart like I could feel
that he had a little bit of reservation
about like he wanted win a Super Bowl
more than anything yes but he just was
there was just a little bit of torn this
in his core that that made me love him
even more than I already did it and like
nobody you know coaches and everyone
else did go on and they're just gonna
you know Garrett has a team and he's got
everybody so he's just gonna there was
no I never felt like it was tearing him
up a little bit
whereas with with Jerry it it felt I
felt that from him and gene Jones that
like it just it felt like it hurt him a
little bit and it wasn't that you had to
pick me the player I said because we
were playing so well you have to go with
deck it was just that the fact that he
cared enough to make you feel that way
made me just care about him on another
level almost like he was you know like
you're your dad one guy that definitely
knows the details is Belichick you're
gonna have to sit with him before the
first game of the year are you prepared
for your meeting with Belichick can you
what is that like when you have to sit
there and ask that man questions in a
closed room well I did it like 10 times
last year yeah so we had like I feel
like we did eight straight New England
games right of the year yeah welcome to
CBS was the first one scary the first
one was a little bit because when you
know he walks in you know it's Belichick
you already know right and sure enough
he's got a suit on that's four times too
big you know it's just it's like doesn't
smile or anything so we have the room
and
usually those other people are a little
intimidated when you have a group of
eight people or ten and you're in its
our environment almost that you're
coming into Belichick he ain't
intimidated all he walks in he just sits
there and then that's like you want to
go first time I was like nope you're
you're going for lands Jim go ahead it's
like hey coach Belichick she's like yeah
and he's like so what do you take you
guys you know look like you're gonna be
pretty good this year you know I gotta
get squat and everything's like that's
it you're right and so now are you
sweating I'm sitting here and then
what's that follow-up yeah there's a and
he's like so what do you think about the
above abuzz team they're really good in
the red zone how you gonna like kind of
that or something like that new just
like it's really like that no words no
he's just gonna shrug you're making me
uncomfortable that's how it is most
uncomfortable like 10 seconds so then it
comes to my turn to talk and I'm like
gosh I just I just don't have the
uncomfortable moments right right and so
then I'm just like you know I have all
these questions about football in
general I didn't care about his team
then I just start talking about the
Giants in the 80s and you bring stuff up
and he gets down history land and that's
when he opens up yeah our favorite coach
in the NFL Kyle Shanahan has your
Eastern Illinois guy Jimmy Garoppolo is
there a bond you Sean Payton Jimmy G I'm
sure this is a thing but when you look
at him as their pride that like well I
didn't think there'd be a lot of us
coming from this school and now you've
got like a few you guys in the league
yeah there's like a pride and there's
like a weird competition just underneath
it all to it's perfect like Sean's
always like yeah but you never broke my
yards record through 1,000 more
touchdowns than you it's always fun to
do that and Jimmy such a good kid yeah I
don't know Jimmy that well we've only
talked a couple times yeah but he's
really nice and I know he's a
hard-working kid and everyone loves him
back at Eastern you know me and Sean are
pretty close yeah you know he's like my
John Gurdon right he's your first OC
yeah and I heard he wanted to trade for
you in New Orleans before they got
briefs he did he tried for a little bit
yeah you know it'd still be playing if
you did that but
first he goes out it takes your judge I
mean yeah mister mister I have more
money hi family you told my guy my dad's
joggers guy do you have any money on you
mister wait but so you stole his job and
then what are you stealing my coaches
job I got to pay for my kids how to eat
- so are you ready for it to become Romo
and left ko seriously no seriously
seriously no you need to get out of here
I feel like you and Corona though is
like perfect together I mean who doesn't
like a corona right I listen good right
no I mean a lime with the corona is just
as good as again that's what I drink it
is house yeah that's I turn it upside
down with the lime marinade in there
turn it over spray Thanks have an
awesome year thank